they were then taking these children
back but it seems clear that many of the
young Native children who come back are
not embraced as full they're not adopted
as full members of the families into
which they go they they often end up as
a sort of in a sort of limbo as maybe
domestics in the household you know so
cared for and and fed and clothed but
not necessarily fully embraced as a
member of the family that's part of what
I think is so striking about the
parallel between Frank would the young
pipe man and what William Meharry
because he too as a slave of his own
family was in this sort of limbo right
being both related to but distance from
he'll depart from the people among whom
he grew up
other questions
okay well thank you very much
[Applause]
books for sale in fact I'm just outside
this door and the others
so stick around fill out surveys
that's a good question
and next up on this long book TV weekend
Caesar brios Oh discusses his book
Havana hardball this is from this year's
fall for the book a week-long Book
Festival held in the Fairfax Virginia
area every fall
so welcome to Barnes Noble and Fairfax
season free Oso is a digital producer
for USA Today sports where he served as
baseball editor from 2003 to 2004 born
in Havana
he graduated from with a bachelor's
degree in journalism from University of
Florida in this 25 years as a sports
journalist he's written for the Miami
Herald and the Sun Centennial just to
name a few
so welcome thank you thank you thank you
for coming and I want to thank Paul for
the book and Barnes & Noble for giving
me the opportunity to discuss my book of
hardball so I'm gonna talk a little bit
about it and why I wrote it and then
hopefully answer some questions for you
guys
um so Havana hardball chronicles a
pivotal time in baseball history where
Cuba found itself at the epicenter of
events that would impact Major League
Baseball the Negro Leagues and Latin
leagues for years to come
and I chose to focus on this particular
time period the 1940s at least in part
because of my father and he's on this
photo over here he's the boy in the in
the cap he grew up in Cuba in the 1940s
and 50s as a fan of almond Dadis that's
the baseball cap that he's wearing there
in the picture with with one of his
uncle's I mean that is was one of the
four teams in the Cuban league and he
would tell me stories about American
players who would come to Cuba every
winter to play baseball and among some
of those players that he would tell me
about were people like Tom Lasorda who
went on to become manager of the Dodgers
obviously future Hall of Famers Monte
Irvin ray Dandridge Negro League players
such as Hank Thompson and Terry McDuffie
and also before Chuck Connors was famous
as the rifleman he was just Kevin
Connors a Dodgers farmhand who played
for um indatus so as I started my career
as a sports writer I started to find
some of these players
hired in Florida and began interviewing
them for newspaper articles with the
idea that hopefully one day I'd be able
to write a book on the topic and then
once I learned that Jackie Robinson had
his that his historic major-league debut
basically began in Cuba with Spring
Training well at that point he and the
Cuban League kind of became many of
sessions for me so for some 20 years I
conducted interviews gathered
information collected photos programs
and other Cuban League artifacts and
finally a few years ago when the
University Press of Florida expressed an
interest in publishing my book the
subject was kind of a no-brainer the
stories from my youth were the obvious
choice
so Havana hardball specifically it
focuses on the 1946-47 Cuban winter
league season it's still considered the
greatest finish in league history and
that history dated back to 1878 just two
years after the formation of the
National League here in the United
States that particular year the
championship was decided by a three-game
series in February 1947 between indatus
and Havana the eternal rivals of the
league they had been in the league since
its formation and at the conclusion of
that three-game series Havana erupted
into an epic celebration that spread
across Cuba now as a final day final
games played out what also was happening
was the Brooklyn Dodgers arrived in
Havana for spring training they brought
with them the Montreal Royals their
triple-a affiliate and that team
included former Negro League stars like
Jackie Robinson Roy Campanella Don
Newcombe and Roy Partlow after Branch
Rickey had originally signed Jackie
Robinson in 1945 the Robinson and the
Royals encountered quite a bit of
resistance in Florida during spring
training in 1946 they would show up for
a game and suddenly the game would be
canceled by a by lightning malfunction
or they'd arrive and the stadium would
be pad locked
or there would be a police officer
informing them that there was a city
ordinance prohibiting blacks and whites
playing together so in 1947 Branch
Rickey decided to move the Dodgers
spring training
base from Daytona Beach to Havana
there had been interracial baseball in
the in the Cuban league since 1900 so he
chose Havana the more tolerant racial
climate there as opposed to Jim Crow
Florida but in February 1947 it still
was not entirely clear that Robinson's
rise to the majors was guaranteed he had
to deal with a lot of obstacles in Cuba
he had to learn a new position there was
he had stomach problems to deal with an
injury late in spring training
even segregated accommodation
surprisingly enough Leo Durocher was
something of an absentee manager for the
Dodgers at spring training and of course
there was the petition by players
designed to prevent Robinson from making
the Dodgers so the book the two main
storylines they also play out against
the backdrop of the Mexican League
trying to lure players major league
players to break their contracts and
play in Mexico and why that's important
is in order to counter that Commissioner
happy Chandler declared all the jumpers
as being ineligible to play an organized
baseball for at least five years and and
the impact that it had as far as the
Cuban League was he also declared that
anyone who had played either with or
against the jumpers they also were
ineligible
so Chandler's edict meant that many
Cuban players suddenly found that their
career and organized baseball was in
jeopardy and the Cuban League itself was
now a rogue league so the book explores
these conflicts how they came into being
and how they were resolved and then
looks at what happens going forward so
those are all the the remarks I had
prepared hopefully you guys have some
questions and I'd be glad to answer them
now
if anybody has 20 years in the making
did you travel back and forth obviously
to the island a good bid or no now
actually I did not travel at all to the
island so these were most there were
plenty of interviews with retired
players like I said in in Florida a lot
of the most of the interviews I did
actually with the players in the in the
book were conducted probably between the
early to mid 90s and early 2000s and
then the rest of it was just research I
I was able to get a hold of two Cuban
newspapers through the Library of
Congress da da la Marina and Havana Post
which is an english-language paper in
Havana also The Sporting News did a
remarkable job really covering all the
Latin leagues back then so that was that
was a big source for for research and
the New York Times obviously they had a
writer with the Brooklyn Dodgers during
spring training in Cuba so other than
the interviews that I had done years ago
a lot of it was just looking through old
newspapers there were books that touched
on the subject here and there maybe part
of a chapter or a chapter that mentioned
that especially likes to books about
Jackie Robinson but now unfortunately I
haven't I haven't been able to go to
Cuba my family left when I was five
months old and and I have not been back
I am desperate to get there at some
point yes
yeah did you have a play baseball when
you were little
I mostly pickup games with friends so no
I never played like organized ball you
know on 9th grade maybe like Park League
but I love baseball and always have
thing about this project well the
hardest thing was getting a publisher
like I said I kind of started this thing
20 years ago and made sort of what I
look back now is the you know the the
queries to try and get a publisher I did
I wasn't really focused exactly what the
book would say so I understand why I got
the rejection letters and then time you
know just life happens right you got a
job you can get married you have kids
it's tough to carve out the time to to
to do something like this without
knowing if it's ever going to get
published so I'm thankful that a former
journalism professor of mine actually
put me in touch with the publisher a few
years ago and so once that once I knew
that I had a publisher that was the
motivation I needed to sort of carve out
like three hours a night to write and
read and finish do the research and get
it done yeah that made you focus on that
particular period that you've wrote
about you seem to have limited it to a
narrower focus for sure well a couple of
factors one being my interest but also
there had already been a pride of Havana
is a really in-depth sort of the entire
scope of history of baseball in Cuba so
that book had already been done so when
a publisher expressed interest I
couldn't really say well I'm gonna do
the exact same thing I needed something
and I knew I needed something a little
more focused and because of the I
thought because of the Jackie Robinson's
presence the fact that you had this the
mexican league raiding raiding going on
the greatest season ever in league
history all those factors coming
together at the same time because
that sort of made it a natural place to
start and it also helped that the the
four managers in the Cuban league at the
time although felucca Miguel Gonzalez
Mark Martin Diego and Amanda Maher sons
they were all legends as players in the
Cuban league so when I when I talked
about them as managers I was able to use
that as sort of a jumping-off point to
tell the backstory of the the Cuban
league and with the Dodgers coming there
for spring training that also gave me a
chance to talk that was part of a that
happened every year there would be major
league teams or Negro League teams
coming in for spring training or
barnstorming so that gave me a chance to
talk about what they called their the
American series sort of tend to hit the
back story of all the times that major
league teams had come to Cuba before
1947
um-um-um
I kiss it's kind of a spoiler I don't
know how how spoilers I'm not to ask
questions about specifics and blusher I
may not answer there's a story about
Ernest Hemingway could you kind of sure
there was there are quite a few colorful
stories and that was certainly one of
one of the best ones and again this was
this didn't happen in 1946-47 but the
Dodgers had been coming to Cuba for a
while they did spring training there in
1941 and 1942
and on one of those trips Hemingway at
that point was living in Cuba and had
invited he would run into the players at
casinos at the National Casino whatever
and he invited a handful of them back to
his estate in Cuba and after many drinks
basically got into a boxing match with
one of the Dodgers players and
eventually suggested that they duel the
next morning
so there's many stories like that with
specially with the Dodgers
have you heard from people in the
Dodgers organization no not not at this
point now what's that no he didn't play
in this era he actually played in the
50s so a little later so he wouldn't
have been there at this time maybe for
the next book I am probably what I have
already actually started conducting
interviews I want to do something on the
final days of professional baseball in
Cuba with the Cuban League and also the
Havana sugar King is the triple-a team
that was there at the time when you
write a book like this
if it gets relegated to the sports
section it's all for all appeal might be
limited simply because people don't see
the book I'm not a baseball person I
don't know baseball history but it looks
like a book that I probably will buy and
read and and it seems to me it's a book
that belongs somewhere else other than
just next to football baseball it's a
book that's more than that well I think
whenever you write something about
Jackie Robinson especially at that time
breaking the color barrier you're sort
of bye-bye the top topic itself you're
dealing with more than just baseball I
mean I to me Jackie Robinson breaking
the color barrier is the most socially
significant that in the history of
sports maybe because of the impact it
had as far as the what happened in the
future with the civil rights movement
and having an african-american player in
the majors what that did to further that
cause it can't be understated and I did
try to put the wallet is a baseball book
I did try to put it in the historical
context of the time especially in Cuba
what was happening then or what had
happened in in the past just for example
in what I found in my research was that
from almost from the beginning baseball
went hand in hand with Cuba's war for
independence against Spain they games
would be set up in Key West or Tampa and
some of that money would would go back
to Cuba for the cause for the cause of
Independence and some of the founders of
the Cuban league were also involved with
Cuba's war for independence from Spain
and I kept finding those sort of
political and links during the research
so yeah it it is a baseball book but I
did try to put it in the context of the
historical events of the time
a lot of time there's discussion about
athletes today not knowing the history
of the game behind the do you do Cuban
players today know the history of the
Cuban League that's you know that's it
hard to say I'm not sure how much in
Cuba they know about the past it seems
like they do I mean whenever you see if
you're familiar with it all in Cuba it's
called like kina Caliente the hot corner
is this part in the park in downtown
Havana where guys hang out and just
argue about baseball all the time and
they definitely know about what's going
on here they they get information about
the games here I do think they know
about the history there but as far as
the young players I'm not sure I'd be
curious
anybody else
what surprised you the most about what
you found well a couple one thing that
definitely was surprising and this is
kind of inside baseball so I apologize
for that but I found it fascinating that
if you've ever watched batting practice
and you know the screens that they have
in front of first base and third base
and second base to protect the plate the
infielders while they're taking batting
practice Dixie Walker who was one of the
people instrumental in the petition
against Jackie Robinson he actually
invented that in Cuba I just stumbled
across it reading through the New York
Times stories something I had never
heard of at all he and his family owned
a sporting goods store back in Alabama
where they lived and one of the one of
his teammates got hit with the ball
during batting practice and he decided
to fashion this thing this net or with
held in in a frame to protect them and
there's a quote from Leo Durocher in the
New York Times article from 1947 in Cuba
that said this is fantastic you're gonna
see this used you know in baseball from
now on and he was right but I'd never
realized that it happened I thought that
was just a neat little detail the fact
that it happened during that spring
training so I included that in the book
this wasn't surprising but it was
certainly striking the way newspapers at
the time dealt with race and ethnicity
you I kept running into these references
for example Sal Maglie is he played in
the Cuban league at that time and when
he made his major league debut in 1946
one of the New York papers referred to
him as swarthy Sal or the Giants latest
spaghetti curveball bender you would see
in the you know Cuban players were
quoted phonetically not just in the
white press but also even in the the
black press that covered that was
covering the that was embedded with
Jackie Robinson in Cuba and spring
training and another example even in in
the youth in the Cuban newspapers
I kept finding the cienfuegos team one
of the one of the teams in there being
referred to as the Petro letõs the
Oilers and I thought well that's odd
because they're the elephants this was
the team nickname and in Havana hardball
that's explained that one of their
broadcasters had started had dubbed them
had called them the Petro letõs which
was a term used in Cuba for white men
who like black women and the phrase
stuck it was actually used in newspapers
in fact I hardly found in in the 47 I
hardly found any references to
Cienfuegos as the elephants they were
almost always called the petrol arrows
so I kept finding these sorts of
references both in the newspapers in the
US and in Cuba and I said I'm not
surprised that race was dealt with that
way then but when you see those
repeatedly you know like when I'm on
damar sands and Rafaela made-up became
the first Cuban borns players in the
majors in 1911 of the modern era
newspaper is rushed to convince or
baseball fans that they weren't black so
you just I just kept finding these
references over and over again very
striking
that's next to go with it is there
anything well as far as this no but
someone asked earlier I am already
started writing interviewing for
hopefully the next book which is on the
final days of professional baseball in
Cuba to research that one gosh I hope so
journey women's league via the
professional during the during the World
War two where they had the American
women's professional league they had a
team and they had some Cuban players in
that league as well I don't know
specifically toward Cuba but I mean I
found photos of the Cuban players from
that league and a Cuban team that played
also there in that league
Caeser we all know that editors make you
choose between your children's so what's
not in the book what hit the floor that
you would love to have put in there and
that we're not going to get oh gosh I
mean that since I focused so so much
I was so narrowly focused on this era I
pretty much tried to empty the notebook
on this you know I couldn't although it
allowed me the chance to go back and do
some back story just by the people
involved you know certainly I wasn't
able to go as in-depth on stuff before
1947 but no I tried to I tried to stick
in as much as I could
yes how long did it take for you to to
write the the book over I mean excuse me
I may have missed it earlier I polish
the the writing part probably a little
over a year and a half and I basically
just forced myself from 9:00 p.m. to
midnight every night to to try to write
it I tried to write a chapter a month
and I pretty much stuck to that there
were times when I I took a month to just
do research or to just do to breathe the
chapters I've already died already
written to kind of just make sure
everything was alright but yeah but
about a year and a half of actual
writing and surprisingly about a year
and a half of editing and and and and
proofing and all that that part of it I
didn't expect that someone once told me
it takes about three years and there
ended up being about right from start to
finish
I know this is some nonfiction did you
have to embellish it a little bit add
some stories to it no not at all I found
plenty of colorful stories just weather
in newspaper articles or in books on the
topic yeah I mentioned before the Ernest
Hemingway thing that was a there was a
character a guy from the Dodgers van
Lingle Mongol who also was on one of the
previous spring training trips just for
example caught in a hotel now CEO now
with two women by one of the women's
husbands and and derosha having to get
him out of the country as quickly as
possible
so there was no need to embellish
anything there was plenty of good good
material to work with you know and even
even the conclusion of the of the Cuban
League you know they said well the one
of the pictures had to pitch on one
day's rest and which is you never see
that happening here except with the
Giants maybe last year but but he
started the first game and then set
another pitcher pitched game two and
then he pushed the third game three
three games three days Michener's with
the league yes yeah with the Cuban
League you mean I mean they were just I
mean they were not the the same kind of
characters I don't think that you'd
you'd see here I mean the Commissioner
died um much more with happy Chandler
because of the impact he had in terms of
the Cuban League being a rogue league
you know and and before him Mountain
Landis basically not hearing any of the
attempt not wanting to hear deal with
any of the attempts by the Black Press
to try and push integration but no I did
I didn't really didn't really deal too
much with the the Cuban League
commissioners I don't think they they
certainly weren't the character
that you that you seen with the
major-league eyes and the impact
certainly
yes actually with your last comment how
has Cuba responded with her vet all have
they responded to remarks of your book
have they you know any outpouring the
outcry 'ti I haven't heard anything yet
I mean it's not a political book so I
don't know and it and it you know it's
it's a even though they even though in
Cuba they got rid of professionalism in
baseball it's basically an amateur
league now since since the Revolution I
I think that the country has always hung
on to its baseball past even the
professional baseball pass so I can't
imagine that there would be anything
controversial than that for them but I
have not heard anything now
I'd seem a little bit odd ball but um
was there tobacco use in the league like
there was here oh I'm sure there was I
didn't see anything specific about that
but that was pretty much common in all
baseball so I'm sure especially with all
the American players going over there
your favorite person to talk to or
research throughout this whole process
um quite a few I mean max Lanier was one
of the key players for key pictures from
and Dadis and he he was in my
circulation area when I was at a small
newspaper in Ocala Florida and so I
talked to him several times over the
years Don Newcombe was terrific I talked
to him over the phone back in 97 with
great detail about the Jackie Robinson
spring training and also Sam Lacey he
was a writer for the Baltimore
african-american he was he was embedded
with the with Robinson and the other
players that spring training I talked to
him and back in 1997 - called him on the
phone and he was at that point in his
80s and he was just tack sharp with his
recollection of everything that happened
so there were quite a few great great
interviews well almost all of them
unfortunately passed away at this point
Don Newcombe is the only one of the main
people that I interviewed that's still
around and fellow Ramirez who is the
marlins spanish-language broadcaster
other than that they've all passed away
I mean we're talking about right after
World War two so it you know they would
be in their late 90s I think Don
Newcombe is in his early 90s at this
point yeah so
nope look this is a little bit out of
the book but you would probably know do
you explain why Cuba and baseball are so
interlocked I mean it's it's been what
70 years of tremendous interest in
baseball even now well I mean it goes
back to Cuba was introduced into I mean
baseball was introduced into Cuba back
in the 1860s by the sons of wealthy
families who went came here to study and
then brought the game back there
and I think as I mentioned before the
that it was so interlocked with the
fight for independence against Spain I
think that was one of the main things
that sort of ingrained it in the culture
in a way choosing baseball over say
bullfighting or any of the Spanish
sports was a way of it was another way
of rebellion against the Spanish crown
so it really be thats really why it
became so ingrained in the culture it
was a rejection of all things spain and
an embrace of the united states and in a
way
anywhere else
all right well um if there's no other
questions I just want to thank you all
for coming if you want to buy a book
I'll be glad to sign them and thank you
I appreciate it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
book TV is on Instagram follow us for
publishing news schedule updates and
behind-the-scenes pictures and videos
instagram.com slash book underscore TV
book TV is on Facebook like us to get
publishing news scheduling updates
behind-the-scenes pictures and videos
author information and to talk directly
with authors during our live programs
facebook.com slash book TV
you're watching book TV on c-span -
television for serious readers here's a
look at what's on primetime tonight at
7:30 p.m. Eastern Fox News contributor
Dineen Borelli on her book backlash then
at 8:00 President George HW Bush's
former chief of staff John Sununu
discusses the achievements of that
administration at 9:00 this year's
National Book Award winner Tallahassee
Coates discusses his experiences being
black in America tonight at 10:00 p.m.
Eastern on book TV's author interview
program afterwards
Roberta Caplan is interviewed by
National Law Journal and legal times
reporter Zooey Tillman about the Supreme
Court case that struck down the Defense
of Marriage Act and then at 11:00 Rita
gaybies reports on her family history
including her grandfather's position in
the Gestapo that all happens next and
first up on book TV in primetime
here's Dineen Borelli
Danine Borelli the opening line of your
book blacklash one of the first links
that comes up when you google my name is
an article entitled the black tea
bagging and denene Borelli please it's
quite an opening line and it's the truth
and this is all of the result of me
being a black conservative someone who
is an independent thinker and doesn't
follow the crowd there are people out
there who don't like my message of
liberty and personal responsibility so
what they do is attack me versus having
a discussion with me in terms of what my
views are and where I stand on certain
issues when you google your name and you
see that what do you think I think my
message is getting out there because
when people attack you they try to shut
you down they try to discredit you by
calling you names and that is something
that is not going to stop me from
delivering my message and again I'm able
to tell my story in my book black
laughter how I got off the sidelines of
being a citizen to really be an activist
for liberty and I also think my book is
a great tool for people to have a
conversation with individuals in terms
of what you can do to play a role in
terms of reining in this government that
is going wild in our country
we're to come up with the name I was
just trying to be very clever and
creative and get people's attention but
also the name is is is very synonymous
because people are curious and so that
also brings them in to try to find out
where I'm coming from and what this book
is really all about most negative
comments come from African Americans or
white people I believe it comes from
black Americans there are people who
call me a token a sellout names I can't
even say on this network there are also
some threats that I've received next
time I see you I'm gonna you know beat
you the eff up that kind of thing
and again it's not going to stop me from
delivering my message of Liberty more
from your book white people can be
liberal or conservative in fact they are
free to flirt with communism or
socialism too but why is it that they
seem to have more choices than I'm
supposed to have why can't a black woman
question the outrageous spending of our
and I think we all should question it it
shouldn't matter what color you are
right now I think when I wrote my book
our debt was about 16 or 15 trillion now
it's over 18 trillion we have a
government spending that is really out
of control and I think that's something
that Americans need to recognize because
we're in debt we have to pay that money
back and so this is a burden that is on
our children and our grandchildren and
future generations
why do you say that you don't have the
option to have different political views
oh I do have the option and I think all
Americans should have the option you
know whatever it is that they believe in
but to stand for it and not be afraid to
be criticized or all called names
because of what your views are your
personal beliefs aren't in your book you
take on Jesse Jackson and Al Sharpton
and Charlie Rangel sure in particularly
why why when I grow growing up it was
the same message I heard throughout
different publications in the black
community the blacks are victims
black Americans need special treatment
because of their skin color the three
individuals you just mentioned they are
still selling that same message today
the message of victimization my book
tells people of how I came from growing
up working numerous jobs taken advantage
of all kinds of opportunities and
advancing myself because that is what I
wanted to do for myself and I never fell
for the victim blame game of blaming
white Americans for example because of
the failures that are happening in the
black community I never fell for the
victimization and so I think my story is
a great story especially for a young
people
to see that if I can do it and I can
achieve success you can do it too no
matter what your circumstances are or
your family situation happens to be how
did you come to your political views
I tell you growing up I was a Democrat
because it was something at my parents
that's how they voted and I thought that
was all there was I didn't do any
research I didn't really do a lot of
reading but once I left home in my early
20s and started reading different things
and experiencing different situations
and meeting a number of different people
who had various backgrounds and
different political views that's when I
realized that I have been being I was
being lied to for many many years
especially with the victimization line
if you work hard and you persevere you
take risks doors will open for you as I
mentioned I've worked numerous jobs some
jobs I wasn't always thrilled about but
I always made the best of each its
opportunity in each circumstance and I'm
someone who was able to work at a
corporate company for 20 years in
Manhattan
went to school for 11 years at night
while working full-time because that's
what I had to do to get my college
degree and thank God I'm the first
college graduate and my family which I'm
very proud of and so things are not
instant people have to be patient you
have to have a plan but doors were open
and the opportunities are out there I I
can't say enough how exceptional our
country is but it's really important for
people to take advantage of the
opportunities that are available for
them who are your parents my parents are
still alive they instilled in me a great
work ethic
to respect other individuals and to
basically stay out of trouble because
when you make certain decisions and
choices they will follow you throughout
your life and I think of my parents
every day what kind of work did they do
my father was in Corrections New Jersey
state of Corrections and I worked at a
supermarket at night
yes worked two jobs for over 25 years
thirty years and I saw that I saw how he
got up early and we wouldn't see him
until later in the day or in the evening
for dinner time and I admire my parents
very much for making sure that we got
our education and also watching how they
went about their daily lives to keep a
roof over our head and food on our table
what do they think of you being a tea
partier my parents are very open-minded
in terms of where I stand and what my
views are it's been a treat for them to
see me on Fox News I happen to be a
contributor and they get a kick out of
seeing me on television because that is
a huge audience or four people and they
also know with the challenges that I'm
up against because of my views but they
understand and they understand where I
came from you know growing up as a
little kid of course they know what I
was like they know I was a very
determined child and had my own views
and opinions early on was a little
stubborn every now and then but I don't
think they had to worry about me
because they knew that I would make my
way Danine Borella you include are you
comparing your college experience to
Michelle Obama's blacklash well I
compare it because a lot of the comments
I've heard and read about her is that
she complained about black Americans
going to different universities and how
they were targeted and things weren't
even and I tell you it's about hard work
if you're able to get into school any
school or a trade even a trade if you're
not able to go to college utilize that
opportunity but don't blame others
because you're not advancing to think
the way that you think you should be
it's really up to the individual to make
sure that whatever plans you set forth
are the plans that you follows you just
take advantage of opportunities
where do you include the track story
because first of all that was my first
love
track-and-field I've ran for events when
I was in high school long jump high jump
440 anchor leg and a 440 and 100-yard
dash to call it 100 yard dash back then
and I loved every minute of it I was a
true tomboy loved sports
and I just thought that to mention that
you know I just think it's something for
especially our young people to look at
to really try to think about what you
can do for your future if that's
something embraced something that you
love and lock on to unfortunately I
wasn't able to utilize a scholarship to
go to college because in my senior year
in high school I worked half the day and
I went to school half a day another
great experience for me but again I
wasn't able to go to college right away
but that's okay because I appreciate
what I had to go through because I went
to school at night for 11 years I didn't
squander I didn't waste the opportunity
I utilize every moment every second that
I could to make the best of it
subtitle of your book how Obama and the
Left are driving Americans to the
government plantation first of all what
he mean by government
I mean when there are way too many
individuals who are relying on
government for their everyday wants and
needs and with this current
administration there are record numbers
of individuals who are relying on the
government whether it's energy
assistance housing assistance food
stamps the numbers have gone up because
the policies under this current
administration are harming hardworking
Americans if you look at something like
Obamacare for example the promise was
that people could keep their plan and
their doctors and their race will go
down but that's not what happened it was
an absolute opposite and I've met people
who have lost their health insurance and
who were happy with their insurance and
their doctor and they are experiencing
record rates with their premiums and my
heart goes out to these individuals
they're hardworking people they want to
support their families they don't want
to have to rely on the government but I
do see a lot of people who are in
circumstances that they don't want to be
in because of the failures of big
government
Danine Borelli what made you attend your
first tea party meeting what that's a
real commitment to join any group like
that sure well I tell you it was a great
experience for me to be a prime time
speaker at the Freedom Works march on DC
in 2009 prior to that I was going to the
local meetings I live in New York
taxes are through the roof in New York
and I don't want high taxes because
that's more money out of my pocket that
I could be using for other things and so
I got involved because years ago I
wasn't someone who was focused on
politics and look at this situation that
we're in with the debt and the spending
and government encroachment in our
everyday lives whether it's the light
bulb that you use or the car that you
drive and I got tired of it and so I
started to get involved in it's a
wonderful thing to see Americans a
all across the country get involved in
grassroots activism because it is up to
the citizens to play a role it is up to
them to look at what our politicians are
doing and what they're saying and what
decisions are making and politicians
need to understand it they work for us
they answer to us and so that's why it's
so important I think for people to
recognize what's going on whether it's
locally or nationally and to have a
voice when you saw what happened in
Baltimore what would you like to have
seen as a solution I found that to be
very heartbreaking what happened in
Baltimore citizens basically burning
down their own neighborhoods I also find
that a lot of the decision-making that
came from the mayor and the local
establishment and in the government they
really didn't have a handle on the
situation and so it really blew out of
control
and unfortunately that situation turned
into citizens being pitted against the
police or local law or our law
enforcement under the situation that
should not have happened it was a local
issue should have been held on a local
level but unfortunately we had outside
external influences who came into that
community it really inflated the
situation it may matters much worse
have you experienced racism in your
Monica to tell you the truth I don't
believe I have and I tell you that
because of I'm sitting here with you
today on national Mona's national
network and I've taken advantage of
opportunities if someone told me know
whatever color they were I didn't take
it personally I wasn't offended I just
looked for another opportunity to
advance my goal my agenda to get ahead
for me to sit here and say have I ever
been you know targeted racially I can't
say that I have on our morning show the
Washington journal on suspend we often
hear from viewers that if you are
opposed to Obama to President Obama it's
because of racism something you
addressing the the left the progressives
you have to realize they have all the
bases covered if you're white and you
oppose President Obama you're a racist
if you're a black conservatives such as
myself
touken traitor sellout so they have all
the bases covered but not what they're
not looking at or what the facts are
with all of the spending and the debt if
you look at what's happening in the
black community in urban communities for
example this is just one example
President Obama opposes school choice
why would you oppose a program that
would help disadvantaged children get
out of the cycle that they're in in
terms of a broken household or a parent
who may be incarcerated or a
single-parent household a neighborhood
that is infected with gangs trying to
initiate these children you want
children to be empowered with an
education so that they can think for
themselves be well educated stewards in
our communities and to be able to
support themselves once they get on
there and that's just one example but
there are policies in place that are
harming Americans and are especially
harming those in urban communities when
it comes to education or job
opportunities people need to recognize
what's going on locally in their
communities but also what they can do to
turn those situations around our charter
school is popular in african-american
households I was a former member on the
board opportunity charter school board
member several years ago and the
children I met and interacted with they
knew where they came from from a public
school where there was no control the
kids weren't accountable the teachers
weren't accountable you put them in an
environment where it's a learning
environment a safe environment and where
they feel like they're looking at
they're being looked after and that they
have which they have an opportunity
there's hope for them charter schools
are huge especially in Harlem
unfortunately in New York there is a cap
on the number of charter schools that
are available and the parents have come
out in droves
to demand more opportunities for their
children because they know the dynamics
from the public schools that are failing
these kids their children to the
opportunities and the opportunities are
limited in charter schools because there
aren't enough seats so you have these
lotteries where parents are praying that
you're their child's name or their
number is called so that they can have a
hopeful future and get a quality
education I mean it's a shame how that's
not something that is you know front and
center for people to understand and
recognize the importance of a quality
education for neediest Dineen Borelli is
the Tea Party movement sustainable
whether it's called tea party or not
I see grassroots movement across the
country and I've traveled the country
substantially over the last several
years and I was recently in Illinois
Decatur Illinois we're talking about a
weeknight that over 200 people were out
to hear me talk about my book my story
but also to empower these individuals or
what they can do because they are
concerned about the direction our
country is going in and people are
coming out on the weekends and in the
evenings of bringing their children out
because they want to know what they can
do to play a role and people are being
active and it is a wonderful thing to
see out of that 200 how many were black
there were me
and there are circuits situations where
there may not be any black individuals
there or address you it does it you know
why because they they tell they they go
to the churches they let the black
churches know that we're having this
world you're invited you're welcome
we're talking about education we're
talking about energy we're talking about
empowerment going out you're welcome
and it's unfortunate when they don't
show up but I've also taken the message
to Chicago I've taken the message to
marathon taking the message here Las
Vegas at the end of lacey peak annual
convention last year and people are
open-minded they want to hear what we
want what we have to say and they also
want to hear how they can play a role
and get involved because when government
is involved in our everyday lives that
seems to be a trigger for a lot of
people to stand up and have a voice and
take a stand and try to do something
from your book the n-double-a-cp has put
aside the pretense that it is a civil
rights organization and has exposed its
real agenda as a left-wing promoter of
all things progressive yes they're
another organization the leaders they
don't support school choice and again
why would you take that opportunity away
from disadvantaged children but also
they don't support black conservatives
I've sent them letters I've tried to
speak at their annual conventions my
questions and asks are ignored by the
leaders of n-double-a-cp and they don't
want my message to permeate in the black
community my message of personal
responsibility and limited government
and that also blows away their myth that
blacks are victims and these special
treatment and that is what I heard
throughout the n-double-a-cp convention
last year which was here in Las Vegas
that wasn't the message I heard whether
it was a breakout session or in the big
auditorium room where they had different
speakers coming in
it was mind-blowing but what was very
concerning is that there were a lot of
young college students there they're
basically breeding the next generation
of the make the same mindset which I
find very disturbing was your reception
hostile cordial there was one incident
where I was on the main floor within the
exhibit hall and the woman came up to me
and had her finger in my face and told
me I shouldn't be there because of my
views and was yelling and cursing at me
it made national television and made the
Drudge Report she's one of many who
think and feel that way but I stood up
to her and asked and answered her
questions and she's entitled to her
opinion to mean Borelli what's your
relationship with Jeffrey Immelt and who
is up well I can say he knows who we are
myself and my husband Tom Perrelli
because we've gone to numerous
shareholder meetings with GE and really
used to ask the question of the CEOs and
this is with Jeff and melt you know he
wants the boot of government on the
industry of energy energy so that they
can sell their renewable energy products
so really they're hiding behind big
government where they can this is a
publicly a profitable publicly traded
company mind you but they want the
government you know corporatism to help
with their their bottom line and I think
that's wrong because really that's our
tax dollars being used to influence GES
bottom line
corporate cronyism you call absolutely
cronyism corporatism anytime government
is evolved with big businesses collusion
and I think that's a red flag for
Americans to recognize when that happens
who is Tom Perrelli he's my other hand
my husband and we are well known at
different shareholder meetings we've
been to numerous and we make the news
and again it's another way for people to
be empowered ask the questions why are
you making these decisions or choices
that are not in the best interests of
shareholders simple question but CII's
don't like to be put on the spot like
that especially in front of the board
and in front of the shareholders where
where did you and Tom meet we met it's
work we used to work at Philip Morris so
we met in Manhattan a number of years
ago and we make a great team because we
have the same mindset it's all about
liberty and freedom and we think it's
important to educate individuals and you
know get people fired up to get them
involved and what they can do we're just
two people but we've been able to make a
lot of noise and gained a lot of
traction we have a huge social media
following on Twitter and Facebook and
people recognize this just from walking
the floors here at this event which is
great and
great here at Freedom Fest are you
seeing some black American faces oh yeah
oh yeah I know a number of black
conservatives and I tell you a number of
years ago I probably couldn't count them
on one hand but I've been contacted on
social media from numerous individuals
who thanked me for what I do would thank
me for my voice and they have my book
and they tell me it's been an
inspiration for them to not be afraid
and not be concerned about when their
friends or the family or coworkers
criticize them because of their way of
thinking because of their views so I
really think I'm able to make a
difference to really draw people out
from being afraid from being vocal
simply because of what they think how do
you think the Republican Party is doing
on outreach to minority community now I
think they should be doing a much better
job and it's very telling because I see
it as drive-by politicians you know when
it's time for them to get elected that's
when you see them they're trying to do
their town halls they might go to the
black community or might not there
they're not really putting forth much
effort like they should be and we're
talking about issues forget the the
labels talk about education you know
school choice as I mentioned earlier
talk about energy which is something
that affects all households we all want
affordable cheap reliable energy but
with the current administration the
policies and regulations are harming the
fossil fuel energy industry think about
it before Obama was president he said he
wanted electricity prices to skyrocket
that doesn't help anyone that doesn't
help anyone on a fixed income in
someone in tune of maybe a poor house
home that doesn't help people who are
looking to how do I get my medicine if I
gotta pay more for my electricity bill
that doesn't help hardworking Americans
and so look at what the administration
is doing and how it's harming
hardworking Americans talk about the
issues whether the people are black
white or otherwise but also what folks
can do to play a role well it's 2015 and
several hundred people have announced
for the GOP nomination for president
anyone that you're favoring at this
point I'm not I'm still watching but I
tell you I I want someone who's going to
listen to We the People and someone who
will honor the Constitution someone who
will abide by their conservative
principles and values because when you
think about it a lot of these
politicians just want to be elected and
stay in office and they'll say and do
one thing to get elected and once
they're there you have no idea who this
person is and so I want someone who's
going to be true to their values and
core beliefs to mean Borelli is the
author here's the cover
it's blacklash you're watching book TV
on c-span - you're watching book TV
nonfiction authors and books every
weekend on c-span - television for
serious readers
[Music]
welcome everybody welcome everybody my
name is Tim Herman and I'm here to
moderate this discussion with Governor
Synanon governor Sununu
was the gun